[Music]
why do
social norms exist and why are some of
them really really meaningful and why do
some of them make no sense at all like
why am i not allowed to wear this hat
right here
to a funeral
okay it might upset some people but why
there is no
benefit there's no direct welfare impact
to society with me wearing this or not
wearing this or wearing something else
on my head this is a question that we're
going to investigate with today's paper
and yes that has no inherent
relationship with machine learning but
as you'll see we can tackle this
question or at least a part of the
question we can give some evidence as to
why these what's called silly rules
might exist using machine learning
specifically deep reinforcement learning
so in this paper people from different
areas of expertise came together to say
can we build a computational model of
society can we build a little world of
agents have them do some behavior give
them some rewards for certain things and
then we just observe what they do and by
observing we can make some conclusions
about huh this could be an explanation
for a societal phenomenon that we see so
i like this paper because it's
interdisciplinary it uses deep
reinforcement learning specifically
multi-agent reinforcement learning in
order to answer questions about society
and it is a little bit out of the box
which i like so the video is structured
i first do a review of the paper by
myself and then i'm going to talk to the
authors about the paper this is one of
the last videos where i recorded the
interview before i did the review but
for this paper it was actually super
helpful because i'm a noob at this field
i don't know what i'm talking about when
it comes to society and research in
sociological questions so it was very
helpful to have the authors talk to me
about the paper but we don't just talk
about the paper we talk about many many
more things and i highly invite you to
watch the interview because it's really
interesting we talk about norms and
societal systems of norms and hypotheses
and what you have to pay attention to
when you do research like this and what
worked and what didn't and what it means
so please let me know if you like papers
like this that are maybe a bit more
distant from what we usually do and if
you do then please let me know what
other kinds of papers and what other
areas exist where ml and specifically
reinforcement learning or any kind of
machine learning are used to investigate
questions in other fields all right i'm
gonna leave it at that and now i'll just
do like a quick green screenshot because
i know people are gonna make emojis out
of my face with this hat on so
and that's that
cheers
hello there today we're going to look at
spurious normativity enhances learning
of compliance and enforcement behavior
in artificial agents by rafael custer
dylan hatfield mannell richard everett
laura weidinger gillian k hadfield and
joel z libo this paper presents a
computational model like a reinforcement
learning approach to research society to
research the phenomenon of what they
call silly rules so the question is our
society has a bunch of norms of what you
should do and shouldn't do and these
norms are
known by the people and they are
enforced by the people you are being
shamed if you don't follow the norms a
lot of those norms are really good like
wash your hands after you use the toilet
but there are a lot of norms that are
also just arbitrary like what kind of
hairstyle is good and bad or acceptable
or not acceptable what words are rude
and things like this and
these are called silly rules and the
question is why do these exist now this
is not a question of machine learning
however this paper applies deep
reinforcement learning in order to
give some
evidence to why these rules can exist so
i like the mixture here of sort of using
reinforcement learning as a tool to
investigate these mechanisms
by using a computational model you can
break down a lot of things you usually
if this were a psychology paper
people would go into a lab they would
recruit people and then they would try
to design an experiment around these
norms and so on and that's that's cool
and all but if you use a computational
model you can answer different questions
you can control for different variables
and so on so it's very attractive to use
reinforcement learning for that so we're
going to look at what this paper says
right here not as much into the rl part
because that is fairly straightforward
but just what it does and what it says
and i'd like just to show you maybe a
little bit because i thought it was
pretty cool
that this is yet another application of
machine learning and specifically
reinforcement learning that enables
progress in a different field
so i hope you you enjoy this um yeah
they they
introduce the paper by saying there are
a lot of norms
something that differentiates human from
other animals society is this presence
is this presence of norms and
some of many of these norms say generate
direct benefits for individual and group
well-being like you know reciprocity
sharing of rewards what you should eat
what you shouldn't eat and so on um
very often these rules have some sort of
a some sort of a benefit to society they
say but however the normative landscape
is also populated by many norms that
appear essentially arbitrary and without
direct material consequences and we're
not necessarily fighting about this like
people can always say well but this rule
may have some some use but let's just
for now let's assume that there exists
norms that really
could be different and it would make not
a difference in total welfare
or at least a direct difference right
the paper here argues that there is an
indirect difference the paper argues
that by introducing these silly rules uh
the indirect benefits are that agents
learn the enforcement behavior of the
rules more clearly and therefore are
better at enforcing the important rules
but we'll get to that in just a second
so here are some of the examples of
silly rules that they
mention men are expected to wear pants
not skirts which in some societies is
the case and others isn't right uh
they're words or hand gestures that
should not be used in polite company
there are rules about how one style of
hair or what one wears on one's head and
so on
so they call these silly rules silly
rules means essentially a norm that is
in society is is very you know taken
seriously but is essentially arbitrary
they say they're meaningful and enforced
um
but they have no direct first order
impact on welfare
so why do they exist there are some
hypotheses they list some here
they say for example silly rules may
remain stable by virtue of their
incorporation into larger normative
systems that also include important
rules which essentially means that the
silly rules they make sense
if they are part of a bigger system that
also contains the important which means
the the useful rules and so the
hypothesis here is that the addition of
the silly rules into a society somehow
helps the society
to comply more broadly or more or more
or better or more accurately with the
important rules so the addition might be
some might be a benefit in the total
um in the total
total
benefit like ah total setup of the
system
in this paper they say we describe a
mechanism through which silly rules can
benefit a society
our argument is based on the dynamics of
learning in a group that lacks a priori
knowledge of which of the rules are
truly important
so they there is a group there's a
society there are a bunch of norms
already present and a priori no one can
tell which ones of those are important
and which ones aren't because if they
could tell they could just say well that
one is not important which is what's
happening kind of with the scientific
method right we know that um some things
aren't as important and with time people
stop doing them but
initially you know there there's no way
of knowing
uh and that's what they investigate it's
important that they say
they describe a mechanism right they
don't necessarily say this is how
society works right because society is
way more complex but they do describe
one possibility one mechanism one reason
why they could why these silly rules
could exist
and they show that this mechanism if you
implement this in a mini society
will lead to a total welfare benefit
their their explanation is the following
the skills involved in third-party norm
enforcement readily transfer from norm
to norm while the skills involved in
compliance are norm specific
what that means is
essentially for every norm you have to
learn how to follow that norm
so these are the skills involved in
compliance they are norm specific
if you know there's a food i shouldn't
eat then i have to learn to avoid that
food and then if there is some sort of
like a way like please share if you have
enough like that's a norm i have to
learn how to do that their claim is that
for many norms the skills to behave in
accordance to the norm are very specific
to the norm however the enforcement this
enforcement skills they transfer from
norm to norm so
what's the enforcement skill for example
shaming someone if they don't follow a
norm that's very that's similar from
norm to norm whether they don't follow
the hygiene norms or the interaction
norms or the food norms or the hair
style norms is always the same to shame
someone into into compliance or to uh i
don't know deduct from their social
credit score or something like this
so they argue that the skill of
enforcing norms transfer while the
skills of following norms don't transfer
as much and therefore they say
the silly rule may provide greater
opportunity to practice third party norm
enforcement and through that
the third parties will also become
better at enforcing the true the useful
norms so the addition of silly rules
might simply make it easier for people
to learn to shame others into submission
and by that they
will be more effective at shaming them
when it comes to the good norms which
obviously they don't know so they're
just gonna shame for all the norms but
overall it is
positive in welfare
so
what they do is they have this
environment right here you can see the
environment right here so up on up here
is a schematic of the environment but
this is kind of the the representation
they are going to have a map which is a
2d map you can see that right here
that's the map and sorry
on this map you have agents so an agent
right here that's sort of a little
person that's walking around the person
can walk around so they can walk up left
right and so on every person sees a
little window around themselves
they see what's happening around there
are sort of obstacles there but there
are also these berries and the berries i
don't know if you can see them on the
screen but the berries this is a berry
these are two berries right here they
come in different colors so the agent's
goal is to move around and collect these
berries every berry they get they get
some sort of points um
you know they they collect them that's
the reward there are enough berries so
that there's no meaningful competition
between agent
um there is one other thing they can do
and that's zap someone they call it even
zapping so in this case i'm gonna guess
something like
this this agent right here is zapping
this agent down here and the the yellow
thing is a punishing punishing beam
essentially that just means that the
agent can zap another agent which will
cause the zapping agent to lose a bunch
of points and the zaphod agent also to
lose more points
um
the only
the only addition now comes with the
poison berries
so
sometimes
some of the berries are poisoned and
there will be a color selected for which
berry is poisoned for example let's call
all the green berries here they're
poisoned
when an agent picks up a poison berry
they are
they they won't see neces they won't see
it themselves but they will be poisoned
and after they pick up a poison berry
100 steps later they will start to lose
health or i think they will just
they will not gain as much from eating
other berries that's it so there's a
very delayed very slow punishment for
eating poisoned berries so it takes the
agent a long time to learn that however
if now if
you get zapped while you're poisoned
that gives the zapper a benefit so let's
call this person alice here and this
person bob
if alice zaps bob and bob is fine then
alice loses some points and bob loses
some some points however if bob is
poisoned then alice gains a bunch of
points for zapping bob so bob is
poisoned loses points and alice gains
points uh by zapping bob i do think so
the zapping cures bob i think so one zap
will actually cure bob but the bob loses
a lot of a lot of points hey y'all it's
yannick from the future i made a small
mistake right here in that i claim that
zapping cures the poison which it does
not uh the idea is that zapping removes
the mark so when a player eats a
poisoned berry in this normal rule
condition they become marked and zapping
cures the mark if you zap a marked
player you get points but zapping
removes the mark it does not cure the
poison the poison is still active
the idea is obviously that the players
learn to avoid the poison in the first
place because they don't want to get
marked
because they don't want to get zapped
and now in the silly rule condition also
a second berry
activates the mark but that's not a
poisoned berry and this you would expect
that it's more noisy and therefore
learning is more difficult but it turns
out under the silly rule condition
learning is actually more efficient and
that's kind of the point of the paper so
again the zapping doesn't cure the
poison it just removes the mark in
whatever way that mark happens to be on
the player in the first place back to
the video
um
yeah there's one last thing and that you
can see here in the marking so when an
agent is poisoned so when they after
they've eaten the poison berry they
become marked which means that all the
other players will see that they are
poisoned now this is the setup
what you can pretty quickly see so no
rules is here
we have
berries and we have poison berries that
give you a delayed punishment
then
this is what i just described with what
what's called the important rule
condition which is that if you eat a
poisoned berry you become marked and
then if a third party another player
sees that they can zap you and they gain
a bunch of points
so you can see that pretty quickly what
is going to happen is that the agents
they learn to eat berries but then
pretty quickly they learn to spot the
marked agents and they zap them
and then after that also very quickly
the other agents will learn to avoid the
green berries because they realize wait
every time i get a green berry i get
zapped later
and
that's how
that's how the agents avoid learn to
avoid the green berry
note
we have to clarify some things this
paper isn't about how the norm of not
eating the green berries comes to be
because obviously that's kind of like
god given right here the marking is done
by the environment the rewards are
clearly set up such that people learn to
avoid the green berries that's not the
issue right here the question that the
paper has is
how quickly can the agents learn to
enforce that norm so
how quickly do they catch on zapping
others right and what what is the
overall welfare so the norm itself is
set by the environment um or by the
designers of the experiment we are we're
not trying to learn to avoid the green
berries be like through the effect of
poison um but we simply directly give
rewards for zapping the marked agents
and that
means we
uh
what means just like we command a norm
onto the system and we see how the
agents react
so
that is obviously
what's happening here is not a secret
right we can all imagine that by the way
the agents they use an actor critic they
use a simple convnet and an actor critic
framework uh to learn right here what i
find interesting is that there are 12
812 neural networks so the system keeps
12 like neural networks um that are
initialized with the same weights but
they're different neural networks and
eight of the 12 i'm gonna just select
three or four right here but imagine
that's eight of twelve eight of the
twelve are then each episode drawn to
compete in in the ring okay they compete
for a thousand time steps then they get
they get their learning updates they get
put back and then for the next thing
eight others are drawn which i found
pretty pretty interesting it's a way to
sort of get diversity um into the system
now what does that what does that have
to do with silly rules so far we've
built up an environment um we we forced
a norm onto it by giving reward for
punishing these marked agents
and
we've discovered that agents learn
pretty quickly to enforce that norm
which in turn makes all the agents avoid
the poison berries as a consequence of
being punished by the norm
now we introduce this silly rule so the
silly rule means that there are poisoned
berries which are these ones but there
are also other berries that we will call
taboo berries the taboo berries they're
just fine they're just you know they're
fine they're healthy you can eat them
you get a bunch of points for eating
them that's fine however if you eat the
taboo berries you will also become
marked just like the poison berry eater
right so these are indistinguishable
markings and therefore
the agents that learn to to gain points
by zapping the poison berry will also
gain points by zapping the ones that ate
the taboo berries what's even worse is
that they also get reward for zapping
the taboo berry eaters so there's no
difference in the reward for zapping
that you get if you zap a poison berry
eater or a taboo berry eater you just
whenever you zap a marked player you get
some points
again it's not about how the agents
learn to avoid the poison berries it's
how they react to given norms right so
again we enforce the norm of you should
eat neither the poison berry nor the
taboo berry of course the agents don't
know which one is the poisonous one
they just know they get zapped after
eating either the pink or the green
berry
so how does that how does that go that's
sort of the question of this paper we've
introduced a silly rule which on a
surface serves no purpose the green the
making the green berry taboo serves no
purpose other than it's just it's just a
rule and you get punished for not
following it it even decreases the
overall welfare a little bit because now
you don't want to eat the green berries
anymore which means that you you don't
get as many points the question is
can the introduction of the silly rule
get you an overall benefit as a society
that's the question okay
so we'll go on a little bit they say our
model allows us to separate the learning
of enforcement and compliance behaviors
from the learning of the norm content
itself that's what i repeatedly
emphasized because i had a lot of
trouble when reading this paper to
really get this they don't want to
they don't want to
they say here we designed an experiment
in which norm content was fixed in
advance by the experimenter namely which
berries are taboo the question is how do
they react to it
so this is a brief recap if a player
breaks a taboo
they change color in the observation of
other agents viewing their transgression
they become marked if a player is marked
other players can collect a reward by
punishing them this creates an incentive
for players to learn to punish rule
violations and thus for players to learn
not to violate the rules
and these are the results we show that
individuals achieve higher overall
welfare in a world where eating the
poison berry is taboo that's condition
one this is this is clear this is
logical we take a delayed punishment for
eating poison and we essentially bring
it to the present by having people zap
the poison people and
them learning to avoid it
however the main result
um
sorry they say even with the cost of
enforcement overall group welfare is
higher with a norm than without we then
show our main result that the value of
the normative order is higher if the set
of norms in this regime includes not
only important rules such as the rule
against eating poisonous berries but
also silly rules which make the eating
of a harmless berry taboo and bring
about the same third party punishment so
they show there is a situation right in
which you can gain by introducing such
silly rules because enforcement skills
are learned faster
let's just quickly yeah look at the
agent architecture if you're into
machine learning or rl or so this should
be rather familiar to you so the agent
they see raw pixels up here there's a
neural network it's a cnn followed by an
mlp
there is an actor critic so there is a
value function and there is a policy
function actor critic
a very basic actor critic algorithm this
is obviously a very easy environment
for reinforcement learning and that
makes it ideal to use multi-agent rl
here to to um
to gain some insights
as we said we have 12 agents 8 out of 12
play in 64 environments in parallel and
they get the replay buffers and they
update this those weights
all right
yeah i've mentioned these things i've
mentioned these things now let's look at
the results
so
first of all
let's look at fraction of time spent
poisoned like how so here is time step
strain so this is over the course of
training right so what fracture fractan
what fraction of of the time do the
agents spent does an average agent spend
poisoned if there is no rule you can see
that
there is a constant fraction of the time
agents spent poison they essentially
over the course of this training they
don't learn
really to avoid the poison berries and
therefore
um yeah because the reward is just too
delayed i guess the rl algorithm it also
isn't too powerful but you can see that
there is a clear difference between uh
the important
rule and
the silly rule so important rule means
there is only one rule shouldn't eat the
poison berries and silly rules that
means that there is in addition this
silly rule
so the agents here quickly they spend
less total time poisoned
and the question is is why
so let's look at some other effects that
the introduction of the silly rules have
total taboo berries eaten you can see
that
at the beginning
about
double the amount of taboo berries are
eaten
under the silly rule than under the just
important rule which makes sense because
twice as many berries are taboo that so
you'd eat twice as many of them in the
same time
but you can see that there is a
crossover this decreases and there's
actually crossover so after a while
less taboo berries are eaten than in the
important rule setting even though there
are more taboo berries right so somehow
these agents learn faster to avoid the
taboo berries total punishments now
obviously again um at the beginning
there are double as many taboo berries
so double as many marked players so they
go the number of punishments goes up
pretty quickly
and then there's a crossover point where
after a while there is less punishment
going on than in the important rule so
these
societies they learn faster and that's i
think the point you can see that at the
end there's often sort of the same
result the same outcome but in this
intermediate stage and remember society
is always in flux kind of uh so one can
argue that very often we are at all
times in sort of this intermediate stage
so in this intermediate stage
it's actually an overall benefit
fraction of time spent marked
goes down as well pretty quickly
obviously because people are more marked
and collective return so here is here is
the actual result
if you have no rule at all
collective return goes up at the
beginning it's actually the highest but
then flat lines right because people
keep getting poisoned and that hurts
if you however
use this important rule thing then at
the beginning it's not as great because
if you punish
these rewards are structured such that
if you punish you decrease the total
welfare even though you as an agent gain
some points the total number of points
in society decreases as a result of
punishment so you can't just punish more
and more and more and expect to expect
the collective return to grow so
yet still because agents learn to avoid
the poison berries through punishment so
at the beginning there's lots of
punishment that's why the reward the
collective return is lower but then they
learn
and as they learn they learn to avoid
the poison berries then they don't need
to punish as much anymore right and then
the reward goes higher than if you had
no rule at all
most interestingly however in the case
of the addition of the silly rule you
can see that at the beginning there is a
decrease in collective return as people
punish around like they punish each
other to death
yet yet
very quickly this goes up and actually
becomes the highest collective return
there is you can see in this
intermediate period right here
there is clear benefit to having these
silly rules around because the society
is much quicker and much better at
learning to avoid the poison berries
because because and you can see from the
time series right here because they
learn much more quickly to punish uh to
punish people who eat the wrong berries
not only the poison but also the silly
ones and because they're much quicker at
punishing the agents have more
opportunity to learn to avoid these
berries and that's what gives you the
higher return
they do they do investigate what these
agents have learned they say psychology
experiments
with human participants address the
issue of learning what people have
learned individually
by isolating specific mechanism and
testing in these controlled conditions
such as reactions to particular stimuli
they want to do the same thing
computationally so they take these
agents from their training run they put
them in inference mode and they give
them like a little environment like this
so they start apart from the berry and
um they episode ends on contact with the
berry so then there you can give them a
berry and see if they eat it or if they
don't eat it
so if you have no rule at all
if you don't have
this marking rule or anything like this
here again it's time step strained but
remember we don't train the agent on
this task we train it on the original
task then at certain checkpoints we take
it out we put it in little lab and we
see what happens
also the y-axis here is inverted so
30 is down here which means 30 time
steps if the line is here it means the
agent has not eaten the berry
if the line is up here it or or like
somewhere up here it means the agent has
immediately eaten the berry you can see
that
in if you have no rule agents they just
eat the berry doesn't matter doesn't
matter if it's poisonous or not right
the pink is poisonous
um it makes a little bit of a difference
but not not really they just eat it
if you add the important rule um
they quickly learn to avoid the poison
berry you can see that right here if you
add the silly rule they also learn not
to avoid not only the poison berries but
also the taboo berries they also in fact
learn to avoid the healthy berries a
little bit more but this comes back over
time in there is a there is a bit of an
unlearning right here and i i do ask
that in the interview
they specifically highlight
um
so these are different berries now
just isolating the times when they give
the agent a poisoned berry
you can see that the reaction to the
poisoned berry is much much bigger
if you have if you are in the condition
that contains the silly rule compared to
if you're in the condition that doesn't
contain the silly rule in this
intermediate regime right here
and also
you know the punishing punishing is way
quicker
so they measure how long it takes you to
punish um it's way quicker when you have
the silly rule and yeah so
that's the essentially the
the evidence
that they say
look
these agents they learn the skill of
punishing they learn the skill of
running after someone who is marked and
therefore
and punishing them and that gives
the agents the opportunity to learn to
avoid poisoned or marked berries
altogether and because there is more
punishment because the agents are better
at punishing more early on
they learn to more quickly avoid the
poison berries so they the overall
argument again is that the skills of
punishing a or transferable between
tasks and the addition of a silly rule
even though it brings some negative uh
cumulative like negative welfare because
it's a rule you need to follow like you
incur some cost it could still be total
benefit overall because the introduction
of the rule just trains people in
punishing others for not following rules
and therefore trains people in following
rules and therefore trains people in
following the important rules
remember in this society people have
don't know the assumption is they don't
know which of the rules are beneficial
and which ones aren't
so these we're on the discussion now
they say from the perspective of an
agent learning the skills necessary to
effectively enforce their society's
norms the additional violations
constitute additional opportunity for
practice and thus promote a faster rate
of improvement in their command of the
mechanisms oh sorry of the mechanics of
third-party punishment now obviously
this doesn't go forever right you can't
just add silly rules until you know
like until the world is just made of
rules and expect well we're always going
to have
much higher welfare
but there is a regime where that is uh
the case and we might as well live in
that regime in our societies
they say enforcement and compliance are
asymmetric in the sense that the former
is a skill that may be applied without
modification to any norm that's
enforcement
since many of the sub-behaviors involved
in third-party punishment are directed
towards the violator for example chasing
them
not towards the event
of the violation itself
thus they are transferable skills
generically applicable to any norm and
yes i get it if you say for example
avoiding food is also transferable and
so on sure sure but
i think this sentence here that
a lot of punishment
behaviors are directed towards the
violator and not towards the event of
the violation itself
that
it makes sense that these skills are
more transferable
the interpretation of our key result is
that the role of silly rules in human
normative systems may in part be to help
train a society's ability to comply with
important rules
and that is the result
the paper goes into more detail
obviously in all of these results in the
setup in why it's important and so on
but i'll leave it at that for now i hope
you you
gain some insights into how
reinforcement learning can help other
fields uh to to get some insights by
modeling sort of these computational
little societies and just introducing
aspects of the real world and then just
seeing how that pans out like it wasn't
clear at all from the beginning that the
introduction of the silly rule here
would bring this improvement in in sort
of the intermediate time frames and
that's just really interesting and it's
kind of a different way of approaching
the questions of why does silly rules
exist in society
questions like these it's a different
way of approaching them than just
putting some humans in a lab which has
its own problems right
so i think this just gathers some
evidence and it's pretty cool
and it's an opportunity for
interdisciplinary research which i like
and i hope this was fun to you as well
and i'll see you around bye bye
hello everyone today i have with me here
three of the authors of the paper about
spurious normativity enhances learning
of compliance and enforcement behavior
in artificial agents jillian hadfield
joel libo and rafael custer
the you you are an assembly of
people with way different backgrounds
that have somehow come together and
focused on a very cool intersection
between machine learning and social
sciences uh welcome to the channel and
yeah welcome
thanks for having us
great to be here so
i mean the first thing first things
first in machine learning we've had
these trends of just making like
click-baity titles i feel your your
field should pick that up because you
know a title like this it's like that is
an instant desk reject you you gotta you
gotta have like a little acronym like
spell or something like just four
letters or so and then you know or or a
question like
um but yeah it's it was it's a pretty
cool
uh
here
we had we we did have a somewhat uh uh
more intriguing title that than the the
journal told us to change
yeah we we did have silly rules in the
title for this for this reason and they
were nervous about that okay you're
there there's still some some
veneer of professionalism in other
fields of science not not in ours uh
yeah i was i was very very happy to see
this paper because it connects something
that i know to something that i don't
know
and
i i think you know us machine learners
were sort of always in the same areas
and this goes a little bit outside of my
comfort zone so i thought it was pretty
cool
how
how did you
get like the idea of writing something
like this of connecting these fields
like where does it come from
i can start with how i came to it uh so
my background's in computational neural
science that's what i did my phd in and
uh
and when i came to deepmind i
was thinking about how do we build a
artificial general intelligence
and reading lots of things about human
intelligence and
realized that intelligence isn't really
in the brain so my whole phd on
neuroscience was maybe not as helpful as
i thought it would be but intelligence
is actually a collective phenomenon that
is more uh supported by how societies uh
work and how um how we cooperate with
each other and learn from each other and
things like that uh and so since then
i've been trying to uh build human-like
agi in a way that is more like trying to
make a society of agis
and this was one one piece of work that
came out of that uh after meeting
jillian maybe jillian can speak yeah
maybe i can say a little bit so so i'm
i'm a social scientist uh i don't build
these systems uh i i think about and
study
how human normative systems work
right those are our systems of norms and
our systems of rules and i'm very
interested in that from a systemic point
of view what are the attributes of the
systems that make them stable and
adaptive
and contribute to
human progress and evolution and uh so
i've been thinking about build you know
working on on those kind of models using
sort of economic modeling tools
and uh joel's team at
at deepmind had produced some papers
studying some very uh
standard problems in the economics
literature on like tragedy of the
commons
and showing how they could use sort of
those multi these multi-agent
reinforcement learning setups to study
tragedy of the commons which is sort of
you know econ 101.
um
i saw those papers got very excited and
said oh but we could really dramatically
you know
increase the sort of the social science
component of
of this work and i had been working with
uh dylan
hadfield mannell who's also on this
paper on this concept of silly rules um
and so we so actually i i think i
tracked you down joel and uh started a
conversation a number of years ago and
um
yeah so we spoke afterwards
yes right oh that's right i came and
gave a talk at deepmind and and uh uh
yeah so so i i was very excited to be to
be connecting up these two worlds
and then you needed someone to actually
do the work and then that's where that's
where raphael came in
i i think i don't have much to add to
joel's story so my background is also in
like cognitive neuroscience and
psychology and i work on topics that are
sort of on the intersection of decision
making and memory in humans and in
ai so certain
social cognition
as well as learning from others or how
groups behave
is
it's similar and also questions of
behavioral economics are all sort of all
in the scope of what i'm really
interested in
so i think this is uh
yeah like a good example of where these
things come together yeah it's it's
pretty cool so to give the brief
introduction
to maybe the paper i i think it's it's
maybe for the machine learners it's
valuable to start with this one right
here so we have this environment there
are different agents inside of it i
think you already always have eight
agents that take part in an episode the
episode can go to up to like a thousand
steps in each step each agent has the
ability to move around uh the goal is to
collect the berries
it has like a like a little window view
around itself of the world and there's
one other action it can like zap
uh someone else right they can you can
zap punish an agent and
we'll we'll get to that in a bit so
these berries that are around you
deliberately made the berries plentiful
so there's no issue of like yeah
competition or anything like this um
there are three conditions that you
compare and these are kind of your
experimental conditions do you want to
maybe
say like if you if you gave the the
pitch
about your own method um i think this
this kind of is the core right here how
would you
describe it
you might want to say what the purpose
was but yeah sure
experimental conditions right
um uh
from from my perspective one thing that
i think falling on from what julian said
a minute ago uh it's true we really did
have a bunch of papers that were kind of
uh
reproducing uh economics 101 kind of
ideas about a tragedy of the commons and
things like that
uh and um
and we got a sequence of those papers
and this was the first time we were
really trying to like contribute back
and say something actually new that's
not just like a new way of coming to the
same kind of results that people already
had in economics for injuries uh
and uh and so this particular area which
we're trying to connect with is is a
field that's interested in cultural
evolution and uh cumulative culture and
things like human uniqueness they see
humans as an ultra social species it's
like critical to um
the niche that we are in uh it requires
a it's a cultural niche we learn from
each other that's how our technologies
work how our societies are put together
and uh
and that's what's what makes us
different from other primates basically
and so within that literature uh
one thing that's interesting is
uh how
is how we cooperate and social norms are
one uh kind of uh mechanism of
cooperation there's others like
reciprocity and things like that
uh
and then within that field there's
another question of like uh we have all
kinds of social norms some of which seem
to be relevant to cooperation and some
of which just seem to be irrelevant
things uh like we can have a we can
moralize all kinds of uh behaviors like
you're supposed to
you know wear clothes and you're not
supposed to
wear a hat in this circumstance or
whatever
and the question then is like well if
social norms are so important for
cooperation
uh why are there all these other social
norms that are like
just not doing that
yeah i mean is
you have this concept of the you have
this concept of the silly rule right
which is a fantastic name and it
describes sort of a norm that
isn't directly
valuable to anything that that considers
like group fitness or even personal
fitness um
yet
does this actually exist like is there a
rule where we can conclusively say this
is a silly rule and not
you know we might be missing some hidden
advantage
well that's the point you can never say
that for any rule really
uh if you're inside the system you never
know whether this is there for some
important reason or or not
but it but i think this is a a key thing
is sort of just a sort of place this
work in the context of the work that
gets done on trying to explain human
rules and norms and so we have people
come at this mostly from a functional
point of view like it's a solution to a
game theory it's a solution to a
coordination challenge or it's a
solution to like a hot dove type problem
where we're going to waste resources
fighting over something um that or
cooperation like joel was saying right
so
most of our work in social science has
come at the question of explaining norms
by saying they serve this functional
purpose
but it seems very clear we have lots and
lots of rules where you could say look
nothing would be different from a
functional point of view
if we said you wear
bright stripes at a funeral
instead of black
or that you you know stand this far
apart rather than this far apart we it's
just once you start noticing silly rules
defined in this way
has no direct
impact on welfare only impact which is
what we're showing
is the role those silly rules play in
helping to stabilize
and a system by which people can enforce
the important roles
right so so i think that's a that's a
key thing so it sort of starts with the
puzzle here's this thing that seems to
be true of every human society you look
at
food rules right what we eat and donate
is often a good example vary tons across
different groups and communities over
time
why do we have them why are they stable
and there's really no good explanations
in literature so we got really
interested in thinking about the role
they play
in supporting what i'd call the
normative infrastructure
which is what you draw on to enforce the
important rules if you're going to
punish people for stealing your stuff or
punish people for going back on their
contracts you need to have coordinated
and incentivized your community to
enforce rules and what we're looking at
is what's the role of philly rules and
helping to create that structure it is a
bit like the the value of
just having rules for and and if you
have more rules then you'll be better at
following rules and
people will be better at enforcing rules
and it's just like
more rules sort of lead to because rules
are uh is it's verbal skill like it's
the enforcement part and that's what you
would want to get at right here so you
your goal is sort of if we train agents
and if we introduce like a silly rule
like this this skill would sort of
transfer to
uh beneficial rules whenever we actually
have beneficial rules so in the in the
first context here there are berries and
and and there are poisonous berries if
you eat the poisonous berries some when
later you'll you'll kind of you know die
but
you'll just your reward will
shrink from eating new berries so it
will be like a very delayed um thing
and
in this case we all we all know
reinforcement learning isn't really good
at super long rewards you also have a
discount factor right so the long
rewards don't even matter like i could
even i could even imagine if a berry is
close to me and i knew it was poisoned
i'd be like meh right it you know it's a
hundred steps away who cares right i'll
just eat it and and i'll go about but
let's assume the agents actually want to
avoid that um
and then you the you have you have a
silly rule and an important rule the
silly rule being
you can you can mark or the rules are
you can mark agents right agents are
marked
if you eat a berry that is taboo you get
marked so you change the color in the
perception of the other so you yourself
don't see it but you change color in the
in the view of the other agents
and
if you are marked other page and other
agents can collect the reward if they
punish you
and
so what we're doing with these three
different conditions is we're sort of
fixing what the norms are
that's the sort of the experiment is if
we if you set the norms what are the
effects downstream on the ability of the
agents to learn to
enforce those norms and to then comply
with the underlying rules that they are
representing
and an important rule condition it the
the taboo berry actually coincides with
the one that is poisonous so that's a
really important
rule for your group to have
that should if everybody learns to
follow it
lead to everybody avoiding getting
poisoned in the silly rule condition you
still have the important rule but on top
of that
you also
get marked for eating a berry that is
fine and doesn't actually poison you so
there's
the potential for twice the amount of
uh
transgressions and then also punishment
behavior
following the important thing is you get
marked just the same so in the third
condition whether you eat the poison
berry or the berry that's fine but just
marked as taboo you get marked the same
so there's no distinction and
the others collect a reward whether
you're poisoned or not it's enough that
you are marked right so that that is how
you
sort of set these norms in place because
i was i was sort of like okay the agents
i don't have to figure out which one's
poisoned like no they do get a reward as
soon as soon as they zap someone who is
marked
and now we we're going to see what
happens in a little bit as a result of
of these experimental conditions but my
questions first is
a motivation to to punish those who have
transgressed
you know normative code and you want to
you know like those those you know they
violated that we want to enforce on them
our social ethic or whatever
the
the question is a little bit so there is
this is like a microcosm right sorry
there's a gap right here
this is a microcosm system and
i you know there's always this
in economics there's always that the
micro economists versus the macro
economists right they and they and
they've
kind of fight because the microeconomies
they come up with their models and their
simulations and their formulas and then
the macroeconomists are like well
if you actually look at the whole world
it's completely different right maybe
you can get some insights right but
there's always this danger of you know
this enclosed system with these very
constrained things uh as soon as you
introduce something else it might just
change the entire game is this
something that you're you're kind of
avoiding somehow or worried about or not
worried about
should i take that one as the economist
in the in the crowd um so i i think
there's there's uh a way in which
what we're doing is is the same kind of
thing that microeconomists which i am um
are are doing which is looking at
you know idealized or schematic settings
and and doing theory about that in order
to
gain insight and generate testable
predictions
and you're not trying to say this is a
map of the world exactly as it is it's
saying we can gain insight into what
would be the impact of changing that
price or that cost or
increasing competition that kind of
thing and so i think what we're what
we're doing here is and we refer to this
as kind of micro foundations which
actually lots of macro autonomous are
interested in micro foundations which is
is can we do a simulation like this to
solve a problem that we can't do closed
form
with our theoretical tools like we would
normally do like you know solve for an
equilibrium or solve for you know a
solution to a game theoretic problem
this is allowing us to solve a much more
complex problem and gain insight um and
then demonstrate this hypo you know
we've got this hypothesis that said our
agents will
learn faster and better to both enforce
and then therefore comply with rules if
there's a silly rule in the environment
so i think of it as kind of similar
methodologically to that
um i think it's got this this
relationship to
uh cultural evolution
not exactly one-to-one we don't think
humans started off like only being able
to recognize pixels in the world
but that that the idea that this is
something that evolves over time but
we're not trying to kind of
model
like evolutionary game theory tries to
in some ways model what would happen
with repeat populations over time so
that's how i think about it methodology
so i think it pays that we now jump to
the results a little bit to to uh take
it ahead before we discuss sort of the
like broader implications or anything
like this so is it fair like correct me
if i'm wrong i character i would
characterize your main
your main um
your main result or your main thing you
derive from it that
if i impose the taboo on the poison
berry
um through this mechanism of agents
getting reward zapping each other
the population will sort of learn to
avoid the poison berries better if then
if if they just get the delayed
anti-reward in addition
if i now also introduce another taboo
berry that's fine this silly rule right
and the agents can collect even more
reward by by zapping
you would say
they are learning the skill of enforcing
rules which is a generalizable skill
and
through by becoming better at enforcing
rules they're sort of faster catching on
to the the fact that you know i should
punish people for eating the wrong
things therefore the whole population
learns to not eat
these types of berries
faster
is that about
in the ballpark
yeah there's there's an evolution of
like the skills or what has been learned
like at first
the agents need to learn to even
perceive the world and then effectively
eat berries that then increases to them
actually
getting poisoned a lot because they eat
the wrong dairy a lot
and
once that is in place and you actually
have a lot of marked agents then it is
possible to learn
uh about the punishment and that it's um
that you can collect a reward
for uh punishing marked agents
once that is in place
then you have the opportunity to
actually learn to avoid the barrier you
want to avoid
because you are avoiding the punishment
but for that you need all of the other
agents to have learned to actually
discourage this behavior so this is sort
of the nice progression of
that one skill relies on another skill
having been learned beforehand
and the silly rule helps exactly in
[Music]
providing more observations and more
training for that learning of
of skills and this is the sort of result
you could only get with a model that is
really focused on learning
of skills
another thing another aspect of it is
there's a very long temporal credit
assignment problem which is very
difficult for enforcement learning in
the case where there's just the poison
berry
but in the cases where they're being
punished for eating that berry then
you're moving closer in time the
negative thing to the
event yeah so it's i think it's this
evolution you mentioned is visible in
the graphs right so you you first have
like the total the total taboo berries
eaten it kind of goes up at the
beginning because you get a reward for
eating berries then
uh people learn to punish others right
so that in time you see that spike after
the other spike and then uh the like
various things happen like the fraction
of time uh spent poisoned and the
fraction of time spent marked they go
down dramatically as a consequence of
the punishments increasing and at the
end sort of the collective
return
uh goes beyond what you would just have
so the difference here i guess is the
credit assignment problem difference
there doesn't seem to be
too much of a difference in the end
result like if you let the game play out
uh between
the
just the
good rule let's say and the silly rule
um
what is like
so
uh your claims are more about
the evolution
of the thing and somewhere in the middle
there might be an advantage to having
the silly rule
is that
yeah i was going to say i think that
that's what's emphasizing that it's
about learning these behaviors of uh you
know the relationship between what you
eat and oh my god somebody showed up and
zapped me
um right learning that and then learning
oh i get this reward if i zap somebody
who
is marked
so learning those behaviors you know
once they're once they're learned in a
stable stable way then the benefit of
the silly rule
uh is kind of okay we we've accomplished
our learning objective my own intuition
is that that uh that the silly rules are
going to help you with robustness so
that when the environment
changes right and so you got to learn
something new so that even though in our
environment it it they it converges at
the end my guess is you then introduce
kind of the shocks of you know the
reigns didn't come this year or a
different we're in a new part of the
world and there's a different
uh dangerous berry
um
then then so i think that's that that's
likely if you search and follow on your
experimental results you have some more
you draw this conclusion that what is
the common thing is sort of the
mechanism of enforcing rules uh the
agents they they learn this this is a
transferable skill and by having sort of
more taboos around they learn this
faster what is different like what
differentiates this hypothesis from the
hypothesis that agents are better at
avoiding
some color of berry because by
introducing you know a new taboo berry i
teach the agents that you know this
newberry is also
taboo couldn't i say with the same
argumentation that
it may be not the enforcement that they
learn in common maybe
avoiding some color of berry
well that's sort of the consequence
right that's the compliance part
from there they can't see anything
different until someone has enforced
something on them uh because if they eat
a berry that is taboo they're marked
only in the eyes of others they can't
see
on themselves uh and for the silly rule
nothing happens at all it's just that
they ate the berry and they became
marked in everyone else's eyes but from
that perspective nothing happened at all
so there's there's no effect on them in
any way until the punishment comes first
okay
yeah
that's the only way that they could ever
then learn to comply um is there us
sorry
and that's one of the nice the graphs in
there too raphael the the sort of
showing that it is that sequence so
learning to punish and then learning to
avoid getting getting poisoned a social
equivalent to uh getting a reward for
punishing someone who has just
transgressed a taboo like if if i you
know think to myself the progression of
this would be it would be more like
if i enforce
some taboo then
long term that will lead to more group
welfare because right um everyone get
keeps to the rule we eat less poison
berries or we follow rules in general
and there's an aspect of group fitness
that also reflects on me uh you chose to
directly give me reward if i punish
someone for transgressing is this purely
just
because you wanted to like hard code
these norms or is there like a social
equivalent to that
yeah i'll let me take that from one
perspective and then i think we can do
it from a few different uh a few
different ones here because this has
multiple kind of ways of thinking about
it
uh
so uh the one you can see it as an
intrinsic motivation agents just are
motivated uh intrinsically to punish the
transgressions of their their
their norm that they have so it's like
there it's some kind of like
righteous anger on the part of the
the agent that just saw this this
transgression uh
and uh and then they're motivated to
punish it and that's a very kind of
natural human emotion that we all feel
uh for for different norms like we could
have totally totally different norms in
mind from different cultures different
places but we might still feel a
um feel some like this is a
transgression that we've just witnessed
i guess whatever it is
that's one interpretation we could have
we have several others uh there's this
interesting one about medieval iceland
maybe someone you could say
yeah let me let me jump in there um
so so so the the fact that humans have
this capacity
um
for
that that they have this practice of
third-party punishment so that's that
really is distinctive about humans in
the evolution of
of uh species
and it's a great puzzle why do humans
spend resources
punishing people for you know doing you
know commit committing harms to others
it's that third-party piece and so we've
got people
in say behavioral economics who think
it's about altruistic punishment that's
a little bit of what but what the way i
understand what joel was talking about
with intrinsic motivation that you just
have a taste for punishing so we get a
whole bunch of of uh in behavioral
economists who study sort of like you
know people willing to pay money to be
able to punish people for hurting other
people
um
but it's a real it's a real puzzle in
the story of cultural evolution about
where that comes from is that second
order like we have
uh we have punishment for people who
fail to punish so we do actually have
critiques that say hey how come you
didn't say anything when that person
uh said that harassing thing to the the
other person around the meeting table
right we we have reactions to people who
don't respond and don't punish people
for violating our clothing rules or our
address dress rules or our contract
rules right
um
and and in this anyways it's a real real
puzzle uh and
you know we're hard coding it here uh
some evolutionary anthropologists model
it as a trait
um a punishment like with punishers and
non-punishers my own view is that that's
actually
that that's the fundamental
behavior to try and explain why do we
end up with humans willing to spend
personal resources punishing on somebody
else's behalf because that's the secret
of our success i was completed
should we do the medieval iceland
example that's what that one's yours
oh minnie delight said yes right so
dill's referring to the fact that i've
sort of been around looking at it it
really is about decentralized uh
punishment so that the key thing to know
about medieval iceland is they had lots
and lots of rules
um
and they had no enforcers no public
enforcers no police no soldiers no
chieftains who had any power
they just have one
individual the law speaker who was
responsible for reciting all the rules
every year at a big gathering
and who was the person you could go and
ask is this allowed not allowed
and that coordinates everybody on
being willing and they had very clear
not only rules but what you could do but
also the penalties like if you did this
you had to give up 10 sheep if you did
that you got kicked off the island
and what you need to do is coordinate
your community
to to actually implement that punishment
and
that's what they did really very
effectively with with zero public uh
enforcement apparatus you know
eventually it becomes more more
efficient to have some enforcement
apparatus but
individuals enforcing the rules is a
really big part of both human history
and even today really important think
about mass mandates
uh think about you know our pandemic
rules where
we're relying very heavily on sort of
community
uh enforcement and non-enforcement i
so the the conclusion
the general conclusion is introducing a
silly rule sort of
makes group welfare
higher or achieves the the welfare
faster let's say um by by mechanism of
you know i learn a transferable skill
and so on so adding one silly rule good
adding two silly rules
adding three adding four like at some
point you know there must be like a
detriment to having you know only silly
rules like how how far would this go out
um is is one like the optimum is there
some optimum of silly rules is this
known can you assess that maybe with uh
with your simulation
uh so we haven't specifically tested
this but
i think your intuition is right that
there would be an optimal number because
also every rule introduces
costly
effects because overall someone
punishing someone else it overall
destroys a reward
so you end up with a net negative so the
more punishment there is it's overall
worse for the group so the benefit needs
to be quite large to overcome the all of
this additional punishment so i think it
would depend on how hard is
um
so first of all how costly are they like
if they're very cheap then you can get
away with more
the other thing is how hard is the thing
that you're trying to learn like if it's
very difficult to learn
the punishment behavior and you need
lots and lots of additional observations
to do so then i think additional rules
would help whereas if it's very easy to
learn then
you'd barely need any additional
observations and you can just then
you're just stuck with the bill so i
think it depends on that i think it it's
some sort of
inverted u shape with like some optical
amount see in these graphs a little bit
that sometimes at the end
actually trends reverse a little bit
especially in
the silly rule case um
and i've seen it here and here is also
prominent in these sort of single agent
tests which you do which i really like
you take a single agent you put it in
like a controlled environment it's it's
not training it's just at some point
during training it's it's like an eval
set uh but also here you kind of see
these
sort of
reverse trends as training progresses
what happens there are they becoming
like
really good do they learn the actual
reward of being poisoned um or what's
going on there do they learn to avoid
the punishers
i
suspect
that what would happen there is some
amount of unlearning because if you are
very effective at teaching the
population to not
get marked and avoid any uh like they
effectively avoid all the taboos
then
uh this behavior just doesn't occur
anymore and you just even forg you will
just forget that you've ever learned
that so i think this would keep running
they might have to
at some point relearn it but then the
question is if they actually would
relearn it because now they're in a
different uh they have competition from
different things like maybe they're very
good at collecting berries now so maybe
they're not as interested anymore as
even learning about the punishment
dynamics at all because the
counterweight of the other behaviors is
is different so i think this yeah this
turns into
i think a continual learning problem if
you just let it run for a very long time
because there's a covariance shift when
the the behavior of marked agents
existing and then being available to
punish is they're the quants
your structure has a bit of a special
thing in it which i found which is that
you have 12 different agents let's say
like 12 different neural networks uh
that you train in every episode you
choose eight of them uh to compete
whereas
sometimes or a lot of times in
multi-agent reinforcement learning i
have like one neural network maybe with
a bit of randomness but essentially
every of the multi-agents has the same
weights let's say they're all shared uh
did was there a particular reason why
you chose this specifically like the not
only having different uh neural networks
for each agent but also to always sort
of select subsets of them and also have
you
the follow-up is have you discovered
that they diverge i would be interested
like did one learn to become like the
punisher like okay i'm gonna exclusively
make my reward off of punishing others
and then others be like nah i'm just
gonna collect my berries yeah and i
think it was just uh
for us not sharing the way it's just
having individual
uh agents one neural network or agent
was always the default for this line of
work and it didn't seem like there's any
reason to change it here in particular
here for modeling humans students don't
have the same policies as one another or
anything like that so yeah
yeah and as an economist or a social
scientist or thinking about these tools
it always seemed like the shared weights
just felt felt like assuming
a can opener right it's just like
assuming you're away the key key part of
the problem which is
uh you know agent a has an incentive to
free ride on the efforts of
of agent b and we're trying to solve the
problem of cooperation and coordination
with with uh
with individual agents
coordination is much easier right if you
make a small gradient change to your
policy in a particular direction but
it's not just you like one agent it's
actually everyone makes that same change
at the same moment than uh for certain
problems secondary coordination not all
problems
i doubt it made a huge difference in
this particular paper though yeah yeah
so i i did not find any specialization
um so i don't think that they are that
they develop different niches but i do
think it should be at least possible
um so yeah that's that's i think one one
of the reasons why we chose it
what what would be
main candidates to add here
uh i'm thinking of things like like in
terms of abilities of these agents if
you wanted to go further like what would
be questions adjacent questions that
you'd like to have answered from such a
simulation and what would need to be
added i'm yeah i'm thinking of things
like
maybe a bit of communication between the
agents some signaling like i could i
could like signal to others that i'm a
good punisher or something like this or
or that
this question and then we can go in a
few directions um uh what one thing that
uh this is very open is where do the
norms come from
here we we just chose like you know this
is a taboo barrier this otherwise
um
uh but what we really want if we want to
have a model cultural revolution is a
model where
the norms themselves can emerge from the
general training the general learning of
the agents and uh
and so that is one direction that we
started to go after this paper we have
another follow-up paper where we have a
way for
the content of the norms to evolve
within the system
but it's also not perfect it has
continual learning problems yeah
arise because if you have uh you're kind
of constantly changing the adaptive
environment for everyone
and you can you can easily break
reinforcement learning that way so i
think the next you know thing that's
going to have to happen in this incline
before it turns into like a real model
of cultural evolution that feels like
you can do the kinds of things we want
cultural revolution knowledge to do
uh it is i will have to have some more
more effort on continuous side basically
make it so that agents can uh can kind
of come up with one norm so society
comes up with one norm and then it can
kind of change tipping point effects as
it changes you can see fads and trends
and things
and
none of that can really happen right now
until we solve some consumer issues
with respect to you know you said
something you know we have yes to solve
continued learning issues and so on what
is
like i'm imagining there are quite a
bunch of hyper parameters in this thing
not only reinforcement learning wise
like what's my discount factor blah blah
blah but also how many points do i give
to what right i can give you gave four
points per berry like well that's that's
just a number uh you give 35 points for
for like punishing someone correctly uh
how sensitive are your findings to these
to these things or how sensitive is the
whole system to these parameters
so i think that's really hard to
quantify because a lot of the changes
would be really meaningful right if you
let's say make the berries so valuable
that you never care about the poisoning
where you make the poisoning so weak
that you don't have to worry about it
any of these things you would expect to
make a big difference because you've
changed the balance of all the different
things that you need to learn about
the thing that we tried that i thought
was really encouraging was is that we
just re-implemented the whole
environment and the agent and also tried
a different
type of learning agent on it and the
results came out very similar so that
kind of
made me
pretty confident about like the overall
observation
that if you
have this type of
social learning problem where you learn
from the observations of how others
treat you if
you get more of those
that helps and that can be
like a key component in like getting the
overall population to the goal faster
how does one avoid
like confirmation bias in these types of
research uh because you you probably
have had some sort of idea of what you
were going for and you know like a
hypothesis
to show and like occam's razor is kind
of a brutal thing right and and and
there is if you see these results you
were like oh yeah this fits perfectly
well with the hypothesis i had and so on
so what
i'm not like i didn't
not that i see anything wrong here but
i'm just wondering uh if you go into
this with the hypothesis kind of what
are the steps one needs to do to avoid
sort of falling into confirmation bias
i mean this kind of thing is
is about uh showing that a particular
mechanism exists
is there and what we don't know is of
course
relative to all the other mechanisms
that are supporting silly rules in the
real world uh how strong is this one
versus other things we could talk about
some of the other ones as well
and there's no way you could ever answer
that from this kind of model
i i think though and you may always say
a little bit that this because it was
you and and our other co-authors that
introduced this idea of testing
individual agents at different points in
training to say can we confirm that that
really is what the agents at these
different stages
are learning or have learned right that
that you know because otherwise you know
we're observing just this mess of eight
agents interacting in this complex
environment over and over again i
thought that was really quite a great
insight and and innovation part of the
innovation in the paper
and raphael you may want to say a little
bit more about that because i think of
that as the the psych lab experiment for
for uh artificial agents in this context
yeah so in
i think you've touched upon this earlier
so one issue of course is with all the
metrics that you just get from the
observations from the whole simulation
is that it's not clear if you can take
them at face value because there might
be indirect effects
um that like scroll up a little while
i think in the
right above yeah right around there yeah
so if you
for example observe
uh that
they spend less time marked is that
because they get punished quicker or is
it because they get marked less and also
of course the dependence of
more
uh
more being marked only creates the
opportunity for being punished more
which then like creates pressure to get
marked less so because everything is
entangled it's really hard to know what
do agents actually
um
what have they learned and how how do
they actually react to individual
stimuli what is it that they're actually
trying to do
so the way we try to approach this is
similar to how psychology tries to
approach it with humans that's like try
to give them a controlled experiment
take them out of the complicated world
put them in like a lab where you just
show them individual stimuli
and see how they react like how quick
are they to pick up the berry that's
what these pictures are these are frames
from that environment it's like test
environment
exactly and then the the results that we
uncover
are very similar to what you get from
the observations so sorry from the
metrics from the whole simulation so
that
although this is a bit of a
like there's some need to do
generalization here this is a bit
different from the world that they
actually inhabit but even if you just
show them one stimulus
[Music]
in isolation
they do pick up they do start to just
not pick up the
the berry that they
the that they have been punished for
frequently so it is like
in that sense like a very clear
uh demonstration that they have learned
the right thing even if the
[Music]
um
even if the presentation of it is a bit
uh
different um
but i'm not sure i'm not sure if it sort
of answers your original question about
the concept that that was my i think
yeah that was my thing it's more i think
it's more about
um
i think this is a big question for all
modeling papers of like what what does
it take for an economic model or a model
of traffic or a model of how a disease
spreads to
be
uh
so good that you sort of trusted to make
decisions based on it i think that's
that's sort of uh
a long path that relies on many
different papers sort of validating it
calibration as well i mean ultimately if
you want to make real world predictions
real world decisions you need to get
real world data into
i think this is also something that
comes from the collaboration between
social scientists and computer
scientists on this because we're seeing
more and more computer scientists
working on models that are interested in
what's happening in the real
world like analyzing language models or
multi-agent environments and
you know when you when you start
bringing in social scientists who think
about exactly this point like okay so
how do i have what's a good experimental
design
that allows me to reliably exclude
alternative explanations for the
phenomenon and and things like and you
you should have a hypothesis before you
start you don't just
run the simulation and say hey look at
this cool stuff we discovered and report
that
um you know you you try to craft
something we spent a lot of time on the
experimental design uh on this one and
to exactly to be able to
respond to your potential critique of
well how do we know you're not just
giving us a just so story about about
what came out of this the simulation
um you you said
something like
uh to the effect of we also think work
like this is very very uh important
towards the direction of agi
do you wanna explain a little bit what
you meant by this because it is of quite
a different direction agi currently that
the biggest yee haw is in the direction
of let's just make one language model
really really really big
uh
where where do you sort of where where
do you come from when you say work like
this might be sort of agi material
yeah i'll i'll start and we can all talk
so
so if you start from a place where what
you want to do is make a human-like agi
and you could say
to make a human-like agi you need to
capture all of the cognitive abilities
that make human intelligence perception
attention memory these kind of things
and you can have a single agent research
program that does that uh but from from
my perspective and i think this group's
perspective
uh
that's not really what's important about
human intelligence it's not that we're
better at perception or memory or
attention or anything like that
than other animals that's not what's
unique to us it's not the secret of our
success it's a phrase that they always
use in this space
but but what is uh the
things that are unique by humans are
these more collective uh properties uh
things about how we cooperate things
about how we imitate each other how we
uh how our cultures evolve and uh
and and that's what you want to capture
so it's not the the individual level
social cognitive abilities it's more
like the group level social cognitive uh
mechanisms which some of which might be
ability-like things like theory of mind
others might be more like
representations or some could even be
like motivations like we talked about
this intrinsic motivation to punish when
you see a transgression
things like that they're not exactly an
ability but they
uh in fact they're they're like not even
things that we think of as terribly
smart uh when they happen
when you see an individual engaging in
those kind of behaviors uh
but at a group level they might have a
have a effect that uh influences our
cooperation and how we learn from each
other and how our norms work how our
institutions can be built and uh and the
way our technology develops and really
uh contribute to all the things that
we're proud of that come out of human
intelligence
so
uh so if that's what human-like
intelligence is then it follows that
studying these kinds of issues is what
we should be doing
uh
and that's where i see this this line of
work all coming together in the agi
direction
and normativity in particular is a
really important thing i think uh
i think it's not it's not entirely just
about uh like if you have a problem
where uh that is a social dilemma or
something you need to cooperate it's
also just about kind of setting up the
rules of the game that organize how we
innovate uh like when we explore and
when we don't and uh
and
norms like broadly construed so that
they eventually include things like
institutions uh
are really uh are critical for that they
kind of are that they set up the game
that we're playing like we all work for
for companies and for universities and
uh and these uh these entities exist and
structure our local incentives in ways
and i think that's really that's kind of
that's how human intelligence has a
group human collective intelligence
works it creates like local rules of the
game for people to play uh so that
intelligence uh can be applied in the
right direction so you can explore and
do things
that's the uh
yeah that's that's where i come out how
i come at it
maybe we should all answer this question
i don't know if i have much to add to
that i think
yeah the
there's the perspective of developing
intelligence from
like cultural evolution of like
populations of agents
uh and then of and then as as joel said
like norms are
particularly interesting because they
are if you have these multi-agent
systems it's all about like the
equilibria
of how
of that the behavior reaches but the
norms are the ones where you sort of uh
take an active
influence on the incentives of others
and that seems like it's a really
important part of like the social
structure
let me add just one thought here when i
give talks on this i as you say look my
favorite definition of of artificial
intelligence is the capacity to act with
foresight and appropriateness in a a
given set of circumstances well that
word appropriate in there uh is
normativity
um what what in this environment it's
not just a matter of physics right like
what's there is notion of how you move a
ball but if you're going to
you know interact with people in a
meeting if you're going to make
decisions together uh all of that is
this structure that humans have invented
i think that's you know it's really
critical to understand that that
normative infrastructure is what allows
us to accomplish so much collectively
and to share information and learning
across groups across
generations
and to pay attention to the fact that
that infrastructure needs to be
generated and maintained by human
behavior and perception
so i think this is to me i say
artificial general intelligence
by definition has to include the
capacity to participate and read this
kind of normative information in the
environment and participate in in in
supporting it so so i i i don't know how
we're gonna generate artificial general
intelligence uh without paying attention
to to normativity so that's what we're
i think that's the connection for me
i think the the proponents of sort of
the scaling hypotheses
they think that models can just pick it
up out of reading stuff or so
um
yeah if it's a static environment right
but if this is dynamic right
um
is there
your research investigates why things
exist why things come to be what you
know why a mechanism might be there is
there a prescriptive element
to what you do would you dare say well
what we figured out here
because of what we figured out here or
over the course of of you know our
research we can
give recommendations to you know
specific things in society of what we
should do
like at some point like you know hey how
about a silly rule here or
like is is there something actually
where you could say uh you know
here's a recommendation i i think i
think so sorry i'm on the recommendation
side i think um
uh yes actually this is a really
critical point and i worry about it a
lot when we're thinking about alignment
problems and so on as we think about
norms and values uh
these
you know there's this idea what you you
know if i asked you at the beginning
do you want to imbue your machine with
just the important stuff or do you want
to give it a bunch of silly stuff as
well silly rules to follow most people
would answer that question but it's well
clearly just the important stuff like
you don't want the machines to be stupid
like humans and and worry about haircuts
and and what fuji and so on
but the point is that those silly worlds
are actually playing a very important
role in this model they're helping to
sustain those behaviors in other work
that we've done uh we've shown how it
contributes to robustness and the
ability for the agents to read the state
of the system the enforcement system
like are the rules being enforced around
here because if not i'm leaving right i
don't want to stay around and be
vulnerable
so i i think a recommendation here is
you know
that actually you need some silly rules
because there are cheap ways for agents
to understand the state of the system
and that's a critical thing to know
uh to decide do i continue to cooperate
or do i go somewhere else
is the scientific method just
this is not no longer about rl i guess
it's the scientific method kind of an
antidote to silly rules because i i
figured you know at some point someone
says hey i've actually tested it and you
know we don't we don't need to avoid the
fish on friday um
it's actually it's actually not doing
not doing anything you know i did my
randomized control trial uh is this
sort of
like what percentage of silly rules that
we have is impacted by this more like
point one percent fifty percent ninety
percent uh like
we mostly don't uh i think we when we
when we have a strongly held kind of
culturally cultural belief like this
uh we don't give up in the face of
evidence most of the time
uh so the scientific method maybe helps
on the margins in some cases uh but but
most of the time the silly rules
overwhelm the evidence
or what we feel more strongly about the
about adhering to the silly rule and
enforcing it than we do about scientific
method
and yeah so
not sure but i'm saying that's
what people do but there's some some
you know argument here that we should
have we are maintaining silly rules for
a reason that yeah this paper's not of
course
but that's not about any particular
solution
and of course any if a silly world
becomes becomes actually a harmful rule
then you really do want to have
mechanisms
where does the where does the journey go
from here for you like in this line of
work what are big
you've already mentioned a little bit
like how do norms appear uh what are
what are other big unanswered questions
uh that you know maybe other people
might who might want to get into this
field might want to take a shot at
another real really interesting one that
i don't know how we'll get to uh below
eventually is uh
how do you get like systems of norms and
then institutions like what's the
relationship between norms and
institutions
uh can we build can we have
institutions emerge within our our
multi-agent systems
uh and what way would they really be
different uh maybe like an institution
has some kind of personality to it or
something like that like it doesn't
matter who the individuals are or
something like that
but we don't nothing like that has ever
emerged
i think two of the things that i'm
really interested in are uh thinking
about robustness and you know are are
the are groups that have
developed these these rule enforcement
and compliance systems
um better able to respond to shocks and
adapt to
new information and changing
environments
and then i i think also you know to what
extent does this become
a you know is this a a more general
mechanism for transfer learning across
settings which is to say all i need to
do when i go into a new environment and
a group particularly if it's already a
stable group
is i need to look around and figure out
what do these people think you know what
are you going to get punished for around
here what are you supposed to punish
around here
and and that can mean you learn a lot
very very quickly which is how humans
kind of work right we
you got dropped down in the in the um in
the arctic and you're lucky enough to
land in a you know among the inuit but
the first thing you would do is say
whatever those folks think is right or
wrong to do that's what i'm gonna do
unfortunately they'll be punishing you
and throwing you out if you violate the
rules so you even have an added
incentive to to not think you can figure
it out better than they can
so i'm interested in that in that
the idea that having this structure in
place actually is is part of what makes
us so intelligent as we go down into new
into new environments
excellent
is there anything else about this
research that you want people to know
you want to shout out um
anything that is important do you feel
we didn't touch on
well one more thing uh so
this paper along with all the other
papers we've written recently they
generate both environments and agents
which we also package up together in an
evaluation protocol in sweden
environments that we've released
which is called melting pot
so it's uh anyone who wants to do
multi-reinforcement learning research on
environments that look vaguely like this
uh but on many different topics uh
multipod is the place to go we've put
out a
large number of different ones we're
putting out more all the time and
it's a
it's a platform for for doing voltage
reinforcement or research and having it
having benchmarks you can compare to
between algorithms and things cool in
this case uh raphael jillian joel thank
you so much for being here i learned i
learned a lot um i hope to see you again
soon
[Music]
you